hello everyone and welcome back to
rotten tomatoes is wrong my name is mark
ellis and i'll just be honest with you
i'm always up front we're down a co-host
jacqueline coley my esteemed the real
star of the show is unavailable today
it's getting into the thick of awards
season and jacqueline not only covers
the award shows for rotten tomatoes she
also goes to all the screenings she goes
to all the after parties but i want to
stress this to y'all she's not doing the
after parties like i would do the after
parties where i just make friends with a
bartender and talk about whether the
lakers can last for 82 games she's
actually hobnobbing she's getting
information she's getting to see who has
the inside track to win all these great
awards so jacqueline is hard at work and
so i'm gonna be steering the ship but i
am not alone today as we talk about the
star wars show yeah we've done the
movies here a bunch of them we've done
some sequels some prequels we know the
classic trilogy lives at top mount
olympus forevermore but now i don't know
if y'all heard this star wars does tv
streaming and the mandalorians season
one and two pretty darn fresh the
mandalorian season one is currently at
93 percent certified fresh and get this
season two
it one-upped its older brother by one
percentage point ninety-four percent
certified fresh for season two right now
on the tomato meter and to celebrate the
mandalorian or possibly to have some hot
takes we have not won but two guests
joining us today they're both from the
hit show force center there's a lot of
podcasts about stores out there i've
chimed in on a few of them in my day but
force center has just built such a great
fan base and it is one of the most
popular star wars shows in the galaxy
we've had joseph scrimshaw on and he
talked about the phantom menace and now
we welcome in the two other hosts of
force center first up is the one the
only
actor performer host contributor to star
wars dot com as well as her fourth
center endeavors it is jen landa jen
hello and welcome to rotten tomatoes is
wrong thank you so much for having me
i'm excited to chat all things star wars
mandalorian specific mandalorian
specific for sure but we could go into
any corner of the galaxy you feel like
and i have a feeling that might be the
case because we're also bringing in your
cohort from forced center he is also the
man who literally wrote the book or at
least a book on star wars why we love
star wars and he is also a very funny
comedian that you can catch performing
alongside me in washington dc december
16th through the 19th tickets at mark
ellis.live but ken knapsock i did not
bring you on just to plug the shows
no look i've been saying mark ellis is
wrong my whole life so i'm happy to be
here and i i know i look like i just
took a break from driving cabs with
danny devito and andy kaufman but happy
to be here with you but all of you here
today
i i did love you in uh in the early 80s
hit show taxi which i caught on nick at
night years later so yeah we are talking
about the mandalorian we have two star
wars experts here joining us so i'm just
gonna put the question ken i'm gonna
kick off with you and then we're gonna
go to jen is rotten tomatoes wrong about
the mandalorian seasons again 93 and 94
certified fresh
no i i think rotten tomatoes is right
and specifically that low 90s range i
love leaving a little room for
discussion a little room for your
personal interpretations a good solid a
minus is a passing grade and i think
it's right it's a passing grade it's uh
way above my standard even though
somehow i stumbled into wake forest
university jen i used to have a teacher
that said she didn't give any hundred
percents to any student regardless if
they used to test because there's always
room for improvement so the highest
score you could get is 99
how do you feel about the 93 and 94
for seasons one and two the mandalorian
is rotten tomatoes right or wrong
i would say mostly right i might go a
little bit higher i do have a bone to
pick with a score of one specific
episode but overall i think rotten
tomatoes got it just right ooh you came
to play this is gonna be fun this is
gonna get good i guess it's my job
because jack was not here to give you a
synopsis of the mandalorians so you got
this cute muppet baby right well
actually let's step back further and
take a look at this bounty hunter that
is within this
cult religion whatever you want to call
it of the mandalorian and so they wear
their armor proudly they wear their
helmets and they never take their
helmets off ever ever ever nobody ever
sees them without that helmet and this
whole storyline takes place about five
years after return of the jedi which we
all know is the greatest film in the
history of star wars or any movie for
that matter and so luke way and han
they're off doing their own thing and
this is following the exploits of one
particular bounty hunter that we come to
know as the mandalorian who has all
these adventures sometimes misadventures
but one particular mission has him
intrigued in a way that he didn't know
he could get and emotionally attached in
a way didn't know he could get because
this mission is to bring this child to
the empire and it's a baby version of
yoda it's not yoda it's just a baby yoda
of the same race that we find out is
named grogu and so through the
adventures of the mandalorian in seasons
one and two we meet a lot of zany
characters a whole host of favorites and
fan debate and we end up well i guess i
can spoil the ending of season two for
you because my brother and i watched it
at the same time we saw an x-wing fly in
and who comes to rescue the child that
the bounty hunter has been painstakingly
taken care of like i take care of molly
the wonder dog for two seasons none
other than luke freaking skywalker
himself and more importantly the
spunkiest droid in the galaxy r2d2 the
one who saved everybody multiple times
shows up they take grogu off and now we
await what's gonna happen in the next
chapters of the mandalorian i thought
that was a pretty good job of keeping it
quick keeping it short producing lucy
was that okay with you i get the thumbs
up from lucy so we are going to talk
about which season we think is better so
there is going to be some dividing line
it's not just going to be a star wars
love fest we can talk about which season
we think should be higher rated on the
tomato meter some bones to pick and the
things that we love the most about the
mandalorians so you're going to hear a
lot more from jen ken and myself and as
for me i think rotten tomatoes is pretty
dead on with its ratings of 93 and 94
i could see it getting a little lower
but i want to keep it in the 90s and for
no other reason just because again this
thing has done what so many people have
doubted could ever be done and that is
unite the current fan base known as star
wars mostly into one loving mass so with
that we now turn it over to tim ryan our
review creation manager here at rotten
tomatoes for our segment that tells us
what the critics were saying when the
mandalorian was released and the
episodes therein it's two minutes with
tim time
it's pretty safe to say that there's a
firm consensus around the mandalorian
everybody loves baby yoda everybody
loves werner herzog and critics and
audiences are in almost perfect harmony
about the show's overall quality the
series as a whole is at 93 percent that
number takes into account reviews for
the seasons as well as the individual
numbers and there are many more reviews
for individual episodes on a seasoned
level the mandalorian season one is
certified fresh at 93 on the tomato
meter with 36 reviews and it has a 92
audience score on a season level the
mandalorian season 2 is certified fresh
at 94 on the tomato meter with 27
reviews and it has a 90 audience score
almost every episode has a tomato meter
in the 80s or 90s though the worst
reviewed episode is season 1 episode 5
the gunslinger which is it's 73 so what
did the critics have to say in a fresh
review for the first season marianne
johansen of flick philosopher wrote here
is the future of star wars not one mired
in the narrow threads of the movie's
mythology but a story that acknowledges
that there is a whole big complicated
wonderful galaxy to explore in a fresh
review from season two rohan nahar of
the hindustan times wrote it's star wars
in its purest form spare but sprawling
elegantly intimate yet epic in scope
appointment tv at its best so that's the
mandalorian jaclyn mark can i offer you
a libation to celebrate the closing of
our shared narrative back to you folks
well thank you tim i imagine jaclyn
might be at some super exclusive vip
event where she's enjoying a libation
currently for me it's just the ice water
with lemon because it's not noon yet so
let's get into tv talk let's just
transition brian do we have different
music for tv talk or is it just this
[Music]
kind of like a certain uh nfl
broadcasting network that just uses
their same music for baseball as well
now it's time to talk about all things
mandalorian jen i want to start with you
and i'm going to ask you i'm just going
to throw a fastball right down the
middle here where does the mandalorian
as a collective unit so seasons one and
two where does that rank for you in all
of star wars entertainment options so
where does it like do do you have it
somewhere on the ladder of your favorite
movies where would it rank for you
for me personally it would rank right up
there with the original trilogy
i'm gonna say it
i
partially because of the nostalgia
factor and what that represented that
first season when we all got to see
grogu baby yoda for the first time and
like you talked about mark how it united
the fan base it was
so special and it reminded me of when i
was a kid enjoying star wars so it ranks
pretty darn high although i do love the
sequel trilogy as well so yeah i mean i
i love them all and ken you and i have
had many conversations about this
you knew the reveal already that there
was going to be this baby yoda character
and then you got to watch me and our
dear friend christian rubicaba watch
that for the first time that must have
been fun for you absolutely fun
absolutely fun to watch that kind of do
what jen just talked about there uh get
people to you know obviously a lot of
feelings around a lot of star wars
always has been huh there's still people
grumpy about empire strikes back uh
let's be honest uh so to to see to have
it do what it what what jen just said it
did it it did unite because an overload
of cuteness but also more importantly a
big bundle of purpose with that
character
yeah the the purpose is that there's
substance behind the style with who we
came to know as grogu so ken where does
the mandalorian as a whole rank for you
in star wars canon
well i'm always going to cheat with an
answer there's no bad star wars for me
but uh this is this it's pretty high i'm
someone who who takes something from all
trilogies as uh as you know mark we've
had many discussions in the bars uh
about this uh around the world uh i uh i
i put mandalorian really high up there
uh especially season one but i love a
lot of things in season two can't wait
to talk about it especially all the
characters that roll up there uh but i
do put it up there uh and that actually
happened on more of a repeat viewing for
me initially season one didn't grab me
as much as it did other folks but then
uh by the end of it yeah i was on board
okay see i had the same experience with
season two where initially it wasn't
grabbing me as much as season one did so
i am still wrestling and i can be molded
one way or the other by you and jen here
so ken i'm gonna piggyback it right over
to you
why is season one of the mandalorian
better than season two there's no bad
star wars why is season one superior
uh season two did what it needed to do
and what i wanted it to do which is
start to expand the story expand the
universe bring in some wonderful
characters bo katan and fennek shan kind
of return and uh soak all those things
it it made the story bigger and some
people maybe
you know that can rub them wrong way if
it's that's too much but those
characters are there to serve the story
right that we need in season two but
season one i i'm gonna use probably say
this a lot i apologize it is a
collection of beautiful star wars tone
poems and it is this really this the
whole theme of season one is about uh
growth personal change uh adaptions and
uh reprogramming yourself uh
and and also it's a big thing about
parenting too i'm not a parent jen can
speak to that better than i can um but i
think the themes in season one are so
powerful and you know when themes in
star wars start popping out of the
screen that's when i get excited mark
jen are you on team ken and perducy lucy
do you think season one is better than
season two or are you more of a season
two supporter initially my thoughts were
i loved season one um i thought that
doing what they did making star wars so
fun and like you're saying can it there
were so many beautiful episodes visually
emotionally
but with season two i keep coming back
to it and i felt the same way as you did
mark initially i was like i don't know
how i feel about season two it didn't
quite grab me the way that i had hoped
so i went back and i rewatched it
there are some great
fun
moments it kind of felt like they just
were letting loose all the creators
they've already done it you know the
directors the writers they'd already
done it in season one for season two
they knew where they needed to go you
had characters like boba fett well i've
never been a boba fett fan i love him
now what happened how did they do that
they brought these legacy characters and
they made i mean that's a huge
that's a huge accomplishment to take
such recognizable beloved characters and
make us love them even more on screen
yeah let's unpack some of this boba fett
stuff too because boba fett getting his
own book and don't worry kids you don't
have to read it you can just watch it um
but we'll talk about our anticipation
for that a little later but as far as
the character of boba fett jen i was
sort of always on the same page as you
where look
the coolest look in the galaxy okay gets
invited to every met gala but you didn't
see a lot of them and thus i didn't
really see a whole lot of purpose i
didn't understand other than just the
mystery of who this character is why
boba fett was people's favorite star
wars character i will say it was cool to
see that reveal at the end of the first
episode of season two where you're like
oh my god he got out of the sarlacc pit
it's been confirmed but i was never the
biggest boba fett fan either but season
two seems to have changed that tone for
you
absolutely i mean we got to know boba
fett in the clone wars obviously and but
for me as an original trilogy fan it was
kind of almost like a joke you know he
was just this cool mysterious character
that all the fans loved and yeah he has
somehow escaped from the sarlacc pit ha
ha yeah right
so his performance in season two though
it brought the depth it bro we saw the
pain that he's gone through and the life
that he has lived and he is bad ass but
there is something going on internally
he's not just this you know this warrior
he's got some depth to him and that made
me really excited to see where they're
gonna take the character next
well it's interesting ken because if
we're talking specific favorite episodes
my favorite episode from season two
would be one of the ones that does
showcase boba fett and this new role of
sort of like liam neeson in taken that
he's you know i okay i got a special set
of skills and i guess i'm gonna have to
use them again i'm not in the best of
shape but the armor still fits barely
let's put it on and let's go do some
fighting the robert rodriguez episode
that he directed from season two is one
of my all-time favorites now because i
think it's called the tragedy i believe
it's chapter 14 and we just get to see
our guy boba fett back in action where
do you stand on
season two and maybe what would be your
favorite episode from there what would
it be the tragedy would it be the
following boba fett even more so than
mando or grogu it is uh that's up there
number one because we i've hiked up
there right off the 118 freeway in simi
valley so now i can go out there and
pretend to be boba fett uh i like the uh
the one with uh the big bill bill burr
monologue there uh late a little bit
later on that a lot of people love but i
do love this episode and it's
interesting because uh all three of us
talking here are you know let's be
honest we're original trilogy era uh
which means that was our entry point in
star wars and and we all kind of share
that same feeling of like ah boba fett
great design one of the all-time classic
designs but i didn't i didn't gravitate
towards him uh much growing up but i
what that what i think they succeeded on
that episode
is is jen touched upon it is is a little
bit of the identity right he's a clone
but not a clone his father was a not a
mandalorian but was a mandalorian by
creed i'm the greatest bounty hunter of
the galaxy but is that who i am now that
i survived this and that episode
confirms uh his uh lust for violence
revenge a a kid who watched his father
killed by a jedi uh and then but where
does he want to take that and and i was
surprised and and pleasantly surprised
but what they were able to do with that
episode while also still maintaining
that boba fett coolness and for me
middle-aged boba fett now still hitting
the gym but still struggling to maintain
with the nice cloak and the armor you
used to have back in high school love
that look love that feel for boba fett
dad bod boba fett is is what we'll call
him so so if you have you harbor all of
this um you know these nice nostalgic
sentiments getting to see boba fett
actually live up to the promise that so
many fans had since we first met him at
a job interview in the empire strikes
back i still would hire boss for the
mission but that's just my personal take
what is it about
season one and maybe what's the episode
for ken knapsock that says boom right
there that's why season one is superior
um i didn't know what to expect from
mandalorian uh i i i'm i'm someone who
doesn't want my star wars dark and
gritty too much i don't i don't want my
star wars to be just power fantasies and
and episode one wasn't that but uh you
know a lot of the hype a lot of the
feeling was finally we get a dude that's
just gonna start killing people in star
wars and i was i found myself resistant
to that so that episode two pops up and
it is like i said before i'll say
hopefully the last time it is this
beautiful tone poem and reflection on
who you are who you were how could you
find your personal identity everything
with quill is about uh how do you how do
you break down and rebuild who you are
and mandalorian who is this uh guy that
comes from a certain culture certain
upbringing who solves things with
violence who solve things by powering
through to get his way cannot do that he
cannot use those skills and things he
knows to solve the problem here he has
to look at it a new way and i was like
oh my god plus it was funny off-world
jaw was saying
and learning that the jawas have a a uh
patio on the top of the sand crawler for
sunbathing loved everything about that
episode after i kind of reflected on it
and that kind of set the tone for me
going forward with season one jen i i so
subscribe to really both what what you
and and ken have echoed when i when i
saw the mandalorian for the very first
time that first episode of season one i
felt all of those nostalgic tones and
also lucy was talking about where it was
the same feeling i had to be honest when
the force awakens came on and maybe even
a trailer for force awakens where it
felt like this lived in world you know
and and it even you you felt the
desperation of just a township like you
got to see shades of in rogue one and
that was what drew me into it that we're
going to be telling these quiet more
western style stories and from john
favreau's you know own lips to god's
ears that's what he was trying to do is
make this western samurai in the spirit
of what george lucas had intended for
the original star wars so when you think
back to your season one
viewing experience hopefully it was a
little less travel oriented and chaotic
than what ken went through what's the
season one tome so to speak that really
does it for you that you say that's why
i love this show
i love it because it plays on two levels
if you're a casual fan if you don't know
a lot about star wars you can still
enjoy it right it's just great to watch
you can get immersed in the story but
for fans that are more hardcore and want
to dig deeper you can do that too you
can learn read about the books you can
go back to old candidate it's all
connected and part of that i think is
from the collaboration between john
favreau and dave filoni you have the fun
kind of childlike
playfulness that john fravra was
bringing to this of just being like this
fan who's wanted to tell these stories
since he was a kid and you have dave
filoni who's also a wonderful
storyteller but who's bringing that
knowledge from george and all of the
canon and all of that rich backstory
from these characters and you put them
together and that's what i think makes
it so such a likable show across all
fans i mean so much of star wars is so
divisive but everyone can find something
within the mandalorian that they can get
behind whether it's baby yoda or
kavvanth or whoever right there's
creatures there's lots of aliens
different species
you know crazy monsters these are the
things that star wars fans love and have
been waiting for let's keep our star
wars weird and i think that it just it
does that so well yeah and the other
thing that it did kicking off that the
entire show was that it never felt
desperate for your attention you know
like it never felt the need to throw
that this hey guys stars is back look at
all these characters that you remember
it really took its time and pacing with
that so it wasn't until
episode three i want to say the the
deborah chow directed episode where we
got to see the mandalorian really show
his action chops and really show like
this is what i can if you paint me into
a corner i am a cat that's gonna strike
and strike with vengeance it was
thrilling to watch i think chow did such
a great job
piloting that episode and the way that
the action was shot towards the end i
think it's called the sin is uh is
chapter three of the mandalorian and
that was the one that walked me and i
was like okay i'm here for the ride i'm
here for the different adventures these
are all kind of work like mini cereals
in a way um any other episodes from
either one of you starting with you can
that you feel like really highlight what
you enjoy about the mandalorian i i will
go back to uh chapter 15 which is the
believer this is uh and no coincidence
for me that rick familia directed both
these ones i want him to tell more star
wars stories and direct more star wars
stories uh and this is uh this is the
bill burr episode right uh you know
every mark you should do a joke about
boston accents in space it would work
really well for you um and what i love
about it is just commentary on belief
commentary on on choice and and star
wars is very much at its core about
light versus dark but it's really that's
hope versus fear and uh
going towards the light because the
light is there and the choices that lead
you to that and this billboard character
who we first met who's who's a you know
recovered uh imperial uh sharpshooter
who's in the underworld who kind of
doesn't care he's above it all and he
finds a reason to believe and finds a
reason to back a cause that's a pretty
powerful statement from star wars uh and
and i just absolutely everything about
that inglorious bastard style uh dinner
scene there or a break room scene is uh
some of the best star wars i think uh
that's been in a few years and a lot of
people reacted to that because of that
see boys
everybody thinks they want freedom
but what they really want
is order
and when they realize that
they're going to welcome us back with
open arms
to the empire
[Music]
jen
if you think about the the episode that
sort of it gives us the culmination of
where we are now um because you love
season two so much and you think about
that final
i believe dave filoni directed it where
you know again we got this child we we
we realized that maybe it's grogu has
outgrown our ability to take care of
said creature and then an x-wing shows
up it was a risk right there's a lot of
weight to bring luke skywalker back and
the first time i watched it i was not i
was so focused on like the technology
and oh how is you know the de-aging
process and whatever so i was taken out
a little bit when i went back and i
watched it again
that was when i i really understood the
weight and the magnitude of it and i
will have to say i did kind of compare
it to darth vader's uh entrance in rogue
one a little bit right it's almost like
a mirror image of that um the light side
version if you will but yeah it was it's
just that's what i love about the show
is they're like we're going to show you
luke skywalker and fans our minds just
constantly are getting blown oh my gosh
boba fett so yeah that was that was very
exciting to watch it's a very
interesting point you bring up because
it was a big risk but it's almost like
we didn't notice what the risk was in
retrospect because it's like watching
simone biles do a gymnastic stunt where
of course she's going to stick the
landing but if that's me up there it's
not going to end well and so you you
have to you you there's so much care
that gets put into it and then it was
ken it wasn't until months later that i
found out that oh that was actually part
of that was mark hamill just being
de-aged and i'm like i'm just i'm just
here for the stories i guess because i
don't know what's real what's fake
anymore but that was a pretty good way
to end a season it was a really good way
to end the season and and i i too the
first night i had that like is that his
head wait what's what am i what am i
watching it and and sometimes star wars
takes these big leaps with technology
and that's going to be some of the there
might be a false step here and there but
i think overall like you said it's the
feeling in the moment and it was the
right time for that character to show up
i love jen pointing out the mirror image
that's the point of it you got one
hallway scene which is where all the
power and rage in the world won't get
you what you want and the other is this
peace and purpose and knowledge and
defense and answering a call of help
will will lead you to what you need and
that was really powerful to me and it
was luke and you know come on you and i
met jen we all three had that kenner
action figure in the 80s and we'd look
at that and want to see that stuff and
and it served that purpose as well star
wars has that balance between the deep
and the important and the purposeful and
oh my god did you see that and that that
really kind of wrapped it all up there
ken let's kick it off with you here if
you you can highlight the man warren if
you want so you can pick another
character um who is that character in
the mandalorian that really grabbed you
or maybe a character that you say ah
maybe we we could have gone a different
way with this uh for me i love quill as
you can tell uh by those who can see me
my grisly old grumpy beard like i love
grizzled weirdos in star wars and it's
something uh jed and i have discussed at
length with joseph's scripture on force
center we love the grizzled old weirdos
pelimoto's kind of a grizzled old weirdo
in her own way and seeing amy in sedaris
and star wars was fun for an old sketch
comedy fan like myself but quill uh
absolutely just what he represented the
the punch to the heart of uh of of his
passing um uh and and i love everything
with him and i just was watching uh the
episode two the child again before we
got on the air and i just just love that
character love what they did with that
character and the purpose behind it and
uh ed you know i have spoken that was
the early hit of that was the eat my
shorts man of the quotable mandalorian i
think it's been forgotten now by other
quotes but i have spoken is still one of
the best
jen it could be grief it could be mando
it could be somebody else we haven't
thought about yet your favorite
character in the mandalorian is who and
why
i mean come on it's gotta be grogu
not just because he's freaking adorable
but because they got it so right of what
having a toddler is like it just is like
he's grabbing the little ball gonna put
it in his mouth no no i and it's just
such a just really for me is like the
first time seeing um that parental
relationship in star wars in a very real
way in a very sweet way um and it's he's
just that puppet can you imagine being
on set with that puppet i just i i
wouldn't be able to contain myself um
but just
everything the magic behind him and also
you know the puppeteering and
the story it all comes together to
create this really beautiful character
that has rightfully captured the hearts
of
fans old and young like my two-year-old
who was obsessed with him so
yeah it was fun to watch uh to watch
producie lucy just nod in agreement when
you said it's like the actual experience
of trying to race a toddler i as ken and
i can somewhat relate to where we just
try to keep the wrong piece of chocolate
out of our dog's mouths but i mean i
think about you talk about the risk with
bringing luke skywalker into the fold it
was a monumental risk to have a because
that would i mean correct me if i'm
wrong does the entire show fail if we
don't buy
into baby yoda because it was introduced
and and just because of the modern world
in which we live and my first thought
when i saw baby yoda in that dc hotel is
i can't believe this wasn't spoiled
months before the show came out i cannot
believe that somehow they were able to
keep this creature under wraps from all
of us rabid star wars fans who will
screenshot overhead pictures of a set
and try to zoom in
we did not know this was going to happen
and even better yet it it got over the
bar it it can in wrestling terms baby
yoda got over with us
how big of a of a clutch play was that
for baby yoda to work right out of the
right out of the gate look uh you're
absolutely right i mean the fact that
you know you got people getting jobs and
camping out in parking structures next
to some of the sets just to get photos
for their websites how this was kept
relatively secret there was only a
little bit of rumblings right before the
show came out and even then it was like
what are you talking about that that
just showed that everyone on that crew
everyone involved in that show believed
in this and it was a giant risk not
unlike that risk when in the late 70s
george said we're going to do another
one and i'm going to take the most
popular movie in history and i'm going
to uh
make the sequel work or fail based on a
puppet and a murky pool
and that worked that's part of star wars
tradition that's part of what george
established and i think grogu absolutely
just slid right in that role so
perfectly and again yeah you're right
that second episode if if you don't
believe that he is staring at an injured
mando and wants to heal him and can
climb out of his pod if you don't
believe any of that it it might have
fallen flat it it absolutely might have
fallen flat it might have worked like an
episode of muppet babies for you and i i
don't know now that we start talking
about some of the characters season two
is winning me over again because i'm
thinking about all of the great
representation that we got with folks
like like ming nawens fennick was so
great to see her in action and then you
also got another one of those just fans
clamoring for
for decades about seeing this character
in a different way where we got rosario
dawson playing ahsoka tano so there's
just a whole lot going on and
matriculating season two jed i think
that's why i love that season so much is
that those characters prove that we're
not just resting on the walls of season
one with a cool-looking bounty hunter
and an adorable child absolutely i mean
ming-na when what can she not do
when i watch that episode with her and
boba fett and she's you know jumping and
she's a total mercenary she's a deadly
assassin she's very cool she's very calm
and just she's fantastic and so exciting
to watch seeing katie sackoff as bo
katan live action i was so thankful that
they were able to bring her on screen i
mean she's a phenomenal actress
battlestar galactica so
being able to see her her character come
to life was really thrilling um and
yes yes ahsoka tano that was that was a
challenge for me because i i love ashley
eckstein but i thought rosario dawson
did a fantastic job um and dave filoni
directed that episode and it just it
just felt so made me feel warm and cozy
just kind of seeing all of star wars
come together like that knowing that
ahsoka was such a beloved character for
him um and bringing her story to life
was really was really exciting to watch
yeah ken you want to piggyback off that
just being a lifelong star wars fan that
you like jen are where
we know ashley ex9 is the voice of
ahsoka tana we also know her much lesser
known husband happens to be a world
series hero but if you take your
anticipation for an ahsoka reveal did
you smell it coming had you read
something or was that maybe as big of a
surprise as seeing grogu for the first
time i'm convinced beyond a shadow of a
doubt in my conspiracy based mind here
that they intentionally let some of the
casting leaks out so they can hide luke
skywalker at the end it's kind of one of
the thoughts i have like cool you hear
some crumbs cool we got this over here
um i
i ended up yeah i ended up really loving
it so katana when i was part of that
generation that was like what's this
little like sarcastic snippy little yeah
and two like she's like a top five
character for me uh and and love
everything she brings to the table as a
character so it's a big challenge it's a
big challenge jen's not wrong at all
there's a lot of a lot of fans from tano
who have taken such great inspiration
from that character but more
specifically taken inspiration from the
way ashley exxon has represented that
character both in and out of the
recording booth so it was a challenge
but i think i trust uh dave filoni in
that regard he's very protective of
ahsoka tata the character he stands
outside with a shotgun at pitchfork
saying no one's coming to this character
but me
and he it again it's easy to look at
season two and say it's a roll call of
other characters and things we know and
ah there's i know that i know that the
old member berries thing and that's not
the case in season two every character
that shows up serves its purpose for the
story of mandalorian and his growth
denjarin's growth it includes boca temp
but at the same time they start to
you're starting to get beyond their
story bokeh tan struggling for power
that she maybe once had had before lost
at power that dinjon doesn't want wants
to give away but he can't uh fedex shan
and now her connection to boba fett and
can we also just celebrate that book
boba fett will be starring and led by
two wonderful actors in their late 50s
yes i love seeing that kind of stuff as
more gravy shows up in my beard um so
yeah season two did succeed in that
regard and at the end of the day they
won me over with ahsoka i like chad was
little dubious little dubious little
dubious jen
what what is it about mandalorian that
maybe didn't rub you the right way was
there something that you said oh well we
we
misfired with that we could have done
this better
i'll tell you what
i really wanted to see more of pedro
pascal's face i know that the
mandalorian cannot take off his helmet i
know that that's part of the story but
when you hire this phenomenal actor who
is such so great with the looks that he
gives i mean game of thrones right like
how could
i have a hard time with that so i'm glad
that we got to see his face in that bill
burr episode which was which was
wonderful but i want to see more of it
let the man act
with his face
i look it's a great it's a great thing a
lot of it might have been the the season
one stuff about how maybe the
availability pager i'm not i'm not even
going to go into rooms but shout out to
to uh brendan wayne and latif crowder
who who were in that suit for most of
season one and two they're doing great
stuff but pedro is such a good actor
everything in his voice everything about
it that that episode jen you're so right
when he takes his helmet off and the
acting i hope we see more of that there
but again there's a challenge coming to
him he he has learned through boca tend
that he was kind of raised by an extreme
cultist the armorer
it's like it's like shyamalan's the
village where they're from they're like
no don't go outside unless you need
medicine you can't take your mask off
bokeh town's like oh yeah no that's not
the case he's got that they're gonna
have to pick that up and i hope they do
okay that's very very interesting way to
to leave off this conversation i i will
say pedro pascal what he brought even
with his brief screen time with his
actual face i'll tell you what i wanted
him to take his helmet off i don't know
about y'all one of the most intense love
albeit quick relationships in season one
i wanted him to get it on the offer was
there they were both ready to go he was
this close to ripping his helmet off and
just having some fun for once in your
bounty hunter existence i wanted to see
it happen it would have been too early
in retrospect but i wanted to see it
happen am i so bad for saying that
no i thought it was going to happen i
was she's either going to kiss his
helmet like caress it and really go for
it or he's just going to take it off and
i thought this is the moment i think i
went like that i gasped and then i went
oh
nothing happened any bones to pick with
mandalorian for you before we uh close
up shop on this segment i'm sorry i know
jenn very well as a star wars pundit and
fan i'm surprised she didn't answer that
we haven't yet gone back to endor and
seen ewoks in mandalorian i you know i i
definitely want to do that
i'm getting there i'm getting there uh
for me it's interesting it's interesting
i i love it and i'm so you know often
get accused of being too positive star
wars only because i'm finding what's in
there for me to love and to inspire me i
continue to do that uh mandalorian
challenged me a few times with even the
great risks of tech that they took i i'm
obsessed with the volume both in its
potential but also how it doesn't look
cinematic to me sometimes and sometimes
in season one i had to work through this
like
man i just would rather go you know the
akiaki festival the ancestors and rise
of skywalker's one of my favorite
sequences because it's just so big and
it's so around me and i feel the joy
that ray feels in that scene i wanted to
live in that moment and and here we are
we're we're in a sound stage down in
manhattan beach and i can kind of tell
sometimes that's personal for me to get
over and as as the tech got better and
the show pulled me in more i wasn't
worried about that and then i learned
that they fooled me completely i thought
verna herzog's client had an actual
working office it was literally a desk
in the middle of the volume and i was
like oh maybe i'm maybe i'm worried too
much about this technology so that some
of the not acting casting choices but
some of the the choices that uh the
actors were maybe uh you know part of
making of in terms of dialogue and
everything it's the way some of them
were delivered some of the scenes
weren't my favorite uh in terms of just
performances but that's also star wars
tradition as well ask george lucas he'll
say oh you noticed that i intentionally
made the prequels to sound a little
clunky and stiff because that's the
style of the time and that's what i
wanted to put in there whether you liked
it or not i thought mandalorian touched
on that a little bit and that doesn't
always connect with me right away my
only complaint i guess my biggest gripe
about mandalorian and this is more the
nostalgic nerd in me i love star wars
because of the bombastic-ness of the
music and the music in mandalorian is is
very well crafted but i'm just waiting
for that like i'm waiting for that hit
is that a me problem jen
i mean you could just say these notes
like that's like already iconic right so
i think i think a little bit grandson's
doing uh i mean i like it because i
think
there's moments where it's kind of like
got this dubstep
techno sound to it and we're seeing
blurgs and and there's fighting and it
just is so weird but i like the weird
and there's kind of almost like that
disconnect which i think is something
new and fresh for star wars
we love john williams of course but and
probably much needed yeah and we do need
to to
go to new horizons whether it's with
characters or with the music and so i
can accept this is something that i'm
just going to learn how to cope with
uh i love this stuff and i love uh i
love that it's unique and it's instantly
recognizable but i do understand what
you're saying mark and this is in
against mandalorian lugo going center
anyway it's just we're used to sitting
in the theater and then john williams
reaches out grabs you slaps you across
the face with a fish and says you got
the biggest thing in the galaxy coming
at you and and sometimes with mando it's
different it's a different tone and i
hope with some even the other star wars
shows we're going to get i hope we
sometimes just have that boom at star
wars but i will say this about ludwig
like i i i appreciate the risk more than
i would the comfort food of just going
back to what we already know and and
that that's just more me but there is
never going to be anything within the
world of star wars that compares to as
ken so eloquently put it john williams
punching everybody in a movie theater in
the face with the it was it was williams
and lucas one two because williams got
you with the crossover and then
immediately after that done lucas gets
you with the uppercut of the most
gigantic spaceship you've ever seen in
your life just coming right over your
head and that's sort of what we're going
to talk about as we transition with our
own music ludwig if you would
[Music]
so let's talk about the the tv versus
movies of this which everybody loves
having this debate now and i can take my
star wars in any form i'm still a purist
when it comes to the way that i enjoy
seeing these particular stories and it
is in a movie theater it's it's in film
form and i think that a lot of that
debate jen centers around how maybe you
felt about the sequel trilogy whether
you felt like this was still the right
format to tell these news stories and
introduce all of these new characters or
if it was a little limiting so you have
a lot of folks that say the mandalorian
really sets a template for how star wars
should be
going forward
how does this debate land on your
shoulders
i don't think it's it's fair because you
know television the mandalorian there's
just so much more room to play you have
different directors they can go to
different parts of the galaxy they can
have a little bit more fun with the
storylines i think with the movies
there's just so much more weight to it
there's just so many so many more
expectations of where fans expect these
characters to go what stories they're
expecting they come up with these you
know theories myself included about who
rey is and then you know what we get
the theory doesn't come true or whatever
it may be and and people get really
emotional about that but i feel like for
the tv shows there's just a little bit
more um
fun to it if you will and just like it's
there's just more room to play basically
biggest difference for me ken when i
think about the star wars films versus
the the tv show particularly the
mandalorian is that i feel like the
mandalorian has an easier out with
ending its tales than star wars would i
mean you obviously see
whether you want to think it was a
sloppy handoff between jj abrams to ryan
johnson and back to jj whether it was
all premeditated which i don't think it
was um but i still think they pulled it
off well with mandalorian it was a great
end of the season to see wu skywalker
and r2d2 take the child yeah so you're
talking about the end of mando season 2
which favre said i just kind of stumbled
on in the writing process and didn't
plan at all yes you're right um yes um
here's the thing this is this is a big
conversation again we're talking about
sitting in a theater now i i like going
to movies less and less because the
grumpy beard but i love going for star
wars stuff in fact i remember watching
the last jedi next to you mark and we
grabbed each other's knees in excitement
when that movement
yeah
it was a moment it was a moment so i
love that but we star wars is also about
change and growth and letting go that's
the way of the jedi and i'm uh clone
wars
george lucas that's his heart was in
that i weekly television where i can
take time to go in and kind of guide
these wild adventures and do these
character studies that worked and i
think this is the future i'm so excited
for kenobi i'm more excited for andor i
cannot wait to dive into that world
anymore i'm really excited with leslie
headlands the acolyte and we barely even
know what's going to come with that i'm
excited for this era i'm excited to
watch star wars at home but the example
i'll give is uh call this controversial
uh solo star wars story on ken tomatoes
certified fresh 100 because i love that
movie i love that movie as this fun
serial adventure
wild origin story that's also a look at
oppression in the galaxy and the
destruction of the foot of the empire
coming down on the people and what it
meant and what it meant to find hope in
that fear it's such a good story it's
such a fun story but it also didn't have
the stakes of the galaxy and you can't
deny that and that's why i think a lot
of people the end of it were like
no death star blew up if that had been a
disney plus series i don't think you
would have had those kind of complaints
so i have to be i have to be even maybe
against my old uh star wars nature i
have to be open to these kind of stories
both big and small on on the small
screen yeah i'll still say it's just
it's a much bigger risk and endeavor and
it costs more dollars to to make a
feature film than it would be an episode
of a tv show as ken alluded to a little
bit jen because like i i like solo's
star wars story a lot and i definitely
ate at denny's more that month than i
had previously
and then i think about the mandalorian
and even people who say oh this is the
way to do star wars is the serial
episode episodic adventures you get a
break there because it's like a new
issue of a comic book you love if this
wednesday you read the new issue and
it's a dud oh don't worry there's
another one coming out next wednesday
whereas if we see a movie and anything
bugs us about it if we say oh i didn't
like that one scene in the last jedi or
i i didn't like that he threw the
lightsaber away whatever it was we have
to sit with that for so long that it
sort of creeps into our feeling about
the overall product whereas with
mandalorian or any of these other shows
there's always the next train coming
around for me one of my favorite
episodes from the mandalorian is the
prisoner uh with bill burr and uh was
directed by rick famous
and it's just kind of it doesn't it's
just like a heist like a heist episode
right with all these weird characters
coming together and it doesn't really
have many stakes so to speak up but it's
just great to watch visually and it's
just cool to see these characters and
have this like familiar relationship
between the twilights um so
but not everyone i see on here 83
rotten tomatoes i believe it should be
92 at least
um so yeah i just think that there's
just there's just more
more things to consume and more things
you may love as opposed to dislike it's
it's too big of a question that i'm
gonna leave you all with here today if
we were gonna get into who should be the
caretakers of star wars going forward
because i like this collective unit that
has started with favreau and dave filoni
and and kathleen kennedy doing a lot of
producing work with the films and just
making it more of a pixar-style
collective of ideas as opposed to just
one figurehead i think it's too much on
any one person but if i just ask you all
what is that streaming show in the world
of star wars that's coming out and i'm
gonna do the i love doing this on my
show versus on peacock is okay i'm gonna
give you
a tv and you can only watch one
of these new star wars shows coming up
are you taking mandalorian season three
are you gonna go book a boba fett are
you gonna go to the cassian andor show
are you gonna go the obi-wan show is
there another show i'm missing start
with you ken which show is ken putting
on well for you probably your phone in a
phoenix airport wow this is the ah
that's tough and yeah acolyte the ahsoka
stuff kenobi have been waiting for the
canopy thing for a long time it was
going to be a great movie that's going
to be a better show i'll get i'm going
to go i'm going to go with my heart i'm
going to go with andor uh i diego luna
is cassie andor uh there's so much there
again because my favorite era is the 19
years between revenge and the sith and
new hope i'm obsessed with that air i'm
obsessed about the rebellion against the
empire hope versus fear light versus
dark and and and the force emerges in
other ways in these stories i i'm so
obsessed with these little details of
andors a character who grew up as a
separatist his family as a separatist
that's why he doesn't like or trust jedi
like or trust the force who has to do
all these horrible things in the name of
good and the end of rogue one he's like
i just want all those horrible things i
did to mean something and have purpose
that's where he ends up now we get to go
experience that and it's a maybe a spy
thriller in star wars
yeah i i'm going to watch that one jen
ken took cassie and andrew you can take
that as well but you only have one tv
what are you putting on it
the book of boba fett
absolutely because
like i said i did not care for boba fett
in fact i was vehemently saying i don't
want to see any boba fett movie or any
boba fett show
and now i'm like i can't wait for this
this is all i want um and the trailer
was a little bit more subdued than i
thought it would be which i appreciate
because we all know that robert
rodriguez can go
action-packed right so i just i'm
excited because i'm also hopeful that we
might see ewoks somebody's got to bring
him back i don't know who it's gonna be
but whoever it is
god bless you
we we kind of treat them like the
ghostbusters after the first movie like
they saved the city and then now they're
just doing kids birthday parties no
these are the ewoks these are legends
they should have statues in every city
where the rebellion where the alliance
where the good side of the force is
celebrated so we got a vote for the book
of boba fett we got to vote for cassian
andor i am so excited for the obi-wan
show i am apprehensive a little bit
about how much they're leaning on darth
vader if that's going to be just more of
the nostalgic tones or if it's actually
going to be doing service to the story
but then if it serves the story too much
then it makes that fight that we see
them having a new hope a little less
impactful for me anyway but again that's
just me and all the baggage from 40 plus
years of watching star wars that i bring
to the table so i'm just gonna go
mandalorian season three that's what i
want give me more adventures in here
give me more of my friends popping up
give me more new characters to enjoy
give me more of these serialized western
shows like i'm watching high noon again
that's what i want mando season three
three different takes from star wars
fans and look at that we didn't come to
blows at least we almost came to blows a
couple times but we resolved our
differences here on the show thank you
both so much for blessing us with your
forced center knowledge your prowess
joseph grimshaw would have loved to have
been here but he was busy taking a
sunset photo of a martini which if you
don't follow joseph scrimshaw on
instagram some of the it's like a binary
sunset looking at that guy take pictures
of alcoholic drinks at the perfect time
of day jen landa you made a sterling
debut on this show i would love to have
you back talking movies outside of the
star wars universe you're always welcome
in our little cantina where can
everybody out there find you and
celebrate all the good that you're doing
in and out of the world of star wars you
can find me on twitter instagram tick
tock jennifer landa 11 38 on tick tock
but normally just at jennifer landa just
me and also starwars.com where i share
my thoughts on salacious be crumb
another one of the great characters from
return of the jedi well you're your
partner in crime there's someone who did
spend some time after a misdemeanor
felony in cell block one one three eight
ken knapsock uh where can all the kids
find you when you're not slinging the
yucks or working down at the docks yeah
yeah working down the ducks getting more
jokes for those uh yuck shows yeah uh
you can just go to ken knapsack.com to
find all the things i do uh you know i
have a game of thrones podcast we had
the wonderful fourth center podcast on
which jennifer for years convinced me to
have a new appreciation for the ewoks my
love of ewoks uh comes from jennifer's
passion for the ewok so all credit to
her uh and then i got a new thing i got
a book of course why we love star wars
uh that's available got a new show radio
show called pop rocking radio real proud
of that talking music you know little
rolling stones every now and then mark
so look for uh pop rock and radio on mix
cloud
ken and i had a very good time at the
rolling stones show uh that is gonna do
it for us today once again you can email
us anytime with your thoughts what tv
shows what movies do you want us to talk
about on upcoming episodes of rotten
tomatoes is wrong rt is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com wherever you enjoy
listening to us whether it's apple
podcast spotify wherever else whatever
that platform encourages you to do i
echo that sentiment rate review all that
good stuff thank you so much perducy
lucy brian perez our esteemed guest jen
and ken for jacqueline coley who's
working much harder than i am right now
i am merely mark ellis at mark ellis
live and we'll see you next week on
rotten tomatoes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you